I talked about being like a group of  junkies who relapse gone listen man I  just need some liquidity you know what  I'm saying I just ran into some bad sub  time you know we just had complex  formulas we just didn't factor in greed  and panic you know I just need eight  hundred five billion dollars by Tuesday  yeah no seriously no I would not screw  you again pretty good I've learned my  lesson  no it's not like the other time is all  no these just come in where we come out  he's give me a little bit Jesus I need  to point five trillion dollar back get  me through one week yes I can we copy up  turned out a new $20 bill the new  Geithner $20 bill will be you know  instead of In God We Trust it'll just  say trust me I'm gonna be the little man  say Monopoly like this